in an interview with gq alex smith
some some surprising comments about what
he believed
the washington football team was hoping
he would do or not do last year he said
when i decided to come back i definitely
threw a wrench in the team's plans they
didn't see it didn't want me there
didn't want me to be a part of it didn't
want me to be on the team the roster
didn't want to give me a chance mind you
it was a whole new regime they came in
i'm like the leftovers and i'm hurt and
i'm this liability heck no they didn't
want me there at that point you can
imagine everything i'd been through i
couldn't have cared less about all that
whether you like it or not i'm giving
this a go at this point it makes for a
compelling final 20 minutes to the
inevitable alex smith movie where as he
works his way back he senses that the
football team would rather he just go
away
collect his guaranteed salary for last
year that's why he was still on the team
his salary was guaranteed they couldn't
cut him so hey you may as well have him
on the roster but they didn't want him
to thrive and he did thrive it's amazing
that that's how it ended up but it also
tells me there's no way he's going to be
on that team in 2021 no i i wouldn't
think so i mean again it's it's a a guy
who's had an unreal career i i mean hey
i i'm not going to fault the washington
football team right i mean i i was i was
like what he's gonna play that's scary
and then i mean as we talked about many
times during the year
i mean watching him play i felt like i
was watching my son out there where i
was like oh gosh get down don't get hurt
oh get out of the way don't let him do
that to you i was always worried about
his leg and that whole situation there
so um
he has
i mean unbelievable story there's no
there's nothing to say about that i mean
it's just unbelievable what he came back
from but i don't fault washington and
you know hey good thing it happened
because they wouldn't have gotten the
playoffs without them there's no way
there's absolutely no way they were just
you know obviously dysfunctional at that
position they needed him and really he
was just the right guy for
the way that team was set up for this
year to take control you know take care
of the ball you know just take a chance
every now and then when i really have to
and play through the defense and of
course it worked out but i'm with you
mike i mean
i i i want to say please retire i don't
mean that in any disrespect to alex
smith i wanted to say please retire it's
been a great run it's awesome i don't
want to see anything else happen you got
you got back you played but i have a
feeling he's gonna try to go somewhere
and be a backup quarterback still i i
don't i don't get the sense he's gonna
retire do you
no i don't 19 million in non-guaranteed
salary and compensation this year from
washington he will be cut undoubtedly
looks like they won't be working out a
reduced deal to allow him to stay so
then where does he go and this dawned on
me a week or so ago chicago makes the
most sense it really does he knows matt
maggie he knows that offense he's
thrived in that offense whether he's the
starter whether he's the mentor to a
younger guy yeah but but to me you want
to stabilize that position and you want
a guy that chicago fans could maybe
rally around now they may not be
thrilled about this this angle of we're
going to constantly be worried that he's
going to get seriously injured again but
i think he addressed that last year
that's not the concern right the concern
is does he still have it i mean he's
been around since 2005
he's been through a lot of different
offenses he's he's been through a lot of
adversity uh what did you see from him
last year i mean this is a guy who came
into the nfl the same year as aaron
rodgers there's definitely a gap between
the two guys
in favor of rogers but what did you see
from smith that would make a fan base
say okay i can get behind this well i
think he'd for me i'd want you know he
can manage a football game you know he's
not going to make any like jaw-dropping
throws or plays that way he's really
going to play the game very close to the
vest
and not make a mistake
and really not push the envelope until
he really has to and then it's oh okay
now we're we're down by four all right
i'll start to make so take some chances
and things like that you know yes he's
not going to excite a fan base i think
more or less you know i don't know
there's a part of me that would be like
reluctant to want to have him as my true
backup
maybe as i would want to go like you
know maybe almost a a third stringer
type of guy on your roster at this point
okay just in case my first two go down
now i got him and i would think it would
be a team that you would go hey
we're kind of a really good football
team and if just disaster hit us at
least we got alex smith to manage the
football game and maybe we could still
win football games that way i can't
imagine him asking for a ton of money at
this point of his career or really being
able to
you know command a high high dollar uh
price or anything like that but there's
nothing on film that's gonna teams are
gonna look at and go oh man yeah it's
it's you know he's got it the movement
is less than you know the arm is less
than and i don't mean to say that
disrespectful let alone he doesn't have
an aggressive nature to him either so
i'll be interested to see how it kind of
plays out and who
you know who really wants them because i
do think teams are going to be scared
just because of you know of course the
injury history and and and you know the
everything about and the way he looked
at certain points last year
what would you think about bringing him
back to
the kansas city chiefs as opposed to
chad haney or matt moore who's just kind
of been hanging around his his arm
supposedly was shot four years ago and
he's hanging around on that team would
it make sense to have alex smith back in
kansas city a second set of eyes and
ears and another brain for patrick
mahomes as he continues his development
that there's you could come up with some
good arguments to have alex smith around
for patrick mahomes right now
i mean there's all those are good
arguments the the only thing i would say
is man if he's got a play that's not his
kind of team he can't throw bombs to
nicole hardman and tyree kill that's
just not his game that's the reason he's
not there i mean it really is they lost
that pittsburgh divisional playoff game
you know a few years ago when they were
the number two seed and it was really
his reluctance to push the ball down the
field why they didn't you know win that
football game but here's like to me
here's another scenario just to throw it
out there that i think could make sense
because i think if i'm a head coach i'm
not sure i really want him as my backup
backup like i don't think i would but
like a team like the new orleans saints
let's say drew brees retires now you got
taysom hill and jameis winston and maybe
okay oh man now we're rolling the dice
on taysom hill we're playing lamar
jackson football and design runs and all
that he's got a banged up shoulder now
jameis winston's in there all right well
at least we got alex smith behind him
and we can run the old drew brees
offense with him and still be
competitive and he can buy some time to
me that's like the kind of scenario that
would jump out more more or less
yeah i think that makes sense and and
there is value there from the standpoint
of the kind of teammate he is right
almost like the the josh mccown role the
coach who is on the roster not
wearing the the polo shirt but wearing
the helmet and shoulder pads maybe never
dressing for a game but always being
there in the quarterback room to keep
everyone focused help hold everyone
accountable i think that's the other
part of it too you look for a team where
maybe there are young quarterbacks that
just need the right guidance right need
the right example of what it means to be
a pro and if your third stringer is
showing up early and busting his ass and
doing everything he needs to do
that then maybe that encourages the
young guys to do it and sets the example
for them on how to do it the right way
it's a real thing there's no question
it's a real thing in my early years of
my career i got to watch of course brad
johnson
but guys like brian greasy
you know that was important to me okay
hey yeah he's you know a few years older
than me four or five years older than me
but i got to see how he approached the
game you know jason garrett i was in the
off season with him on the tampa bay
buccaneers got to see what they do and
how he approached the game you know as a
quarterback and of course he had been
around troy aikman and you know the
giants and so many good football teams
they're they're
jim miller i was also with him i mean of
course i was with john gruden we we
collected quarterbacks yearly we had
like a mosh pit of quarterbacks we had a
quarterback room that was seven feet big
it was a seven feet wide seven feet long
and we had seven quarterbacks in there
every year but it really was a great
learning experience for me i got to see
how each one of them kind of approached
the game in their own way and how they
took time on their own to either get
there early or sneak away at this point
of the day and watch some film the way
they wanted to do it and uh there is
certainly great value for young
quarterbacks and learning from guys like
alex smith
what a shock john gruden collecting
quarterback right never heard of that
last week of
john gruden with his
current quarterback and then always
having eyes on basically any other
quarterback who may be out there but but
you know i have a suggestion this week
that derek carr is going to get himself
a contract extension so john gruden very
adept at loving the one he's with even
if he's constantly thinking there may be
somebody else out there who will be
better for me the problem is getting
them and i still believe that i don't
want to make this about the raiders but
i still believe that if something falls
into his lap he'll he'll do it alex
smith is not the kind of quarterback
that would fall into john gruden's lap
and cause him to dump derek carr but but
i think alex smith will have value this
year somewhere it's not going to be
about the money yeah it's just going to
be about still being around it and i
could see him transition into coaching
the way he's been such a great mentor
for other quarterbacks patrick mahomes
raved about him in 2018 when mahomes
took over as the starter in kansas city
so maybe it'll work out that way
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports